[Music]
i fell in love with layla the minute i
saw her video
she's only eight i knew she wasn't gonna
know the whole dance good job laila but
once layla knows the choreography she
has so much energy so much sass and
she's fun to watch
is that nerve-racking because jess
doesn't want
two people to look alike or be alike or
i think it is very nerve-wracking
because
i mean charity most likely they won't
cast two girls that look so similar
you know if you see an outfit or you
know like just style it differently
don't dress them exactly the same
you have to like
make it your own you're saying kaya
copies kinley
[Music]
no i'm just saying they look alike i
don't really feel like they look alike
except that they're both blonde and at
this point they're the two blondes left
i was one of the moms saying the twins i
would have to ask leah when i saw kyle i
was like now that's not kindly right it
was confusing at the auditions charity i
want to be honest with you i know what
they are
thinking and i know what they are
looking forward to all right
i don't really want to talk about it
right now
tracy and i were kind of friends i just
thought her talking to me that way and
in front of everybody was not how i
would handle a situation
she wasn't being honest it needs to be
right i mean
jess brought it up like yeah it was the
elephant in the room and just brought it
up and to be honest
i want what i truly do want what's best
for both of our girls
and and that's not being the same is not
what's best for anybody here
[Music]
i'll play along when i hear my favorite
song
i'm gonna be the one who gets it right
amazing let's just have a great job do
that literally that one spot
i think that we've got the pre it's just
that one yeah it's just that we're just
gonna focus on this one little piece
there's a lot of pressure actually to do
well
last week was just okay for me they
didn't really notice me they said i was
getting better it's like you can't just
stay the same they have to see your
improvement every week
so it's it's scary but i think i can do
it
don't feel like dancing dancing even if
i find out for me to do don't feel like
dancing dancing why don't you break it
down when i'm not in the mood wow
awesome so what i need from you is a
huge breath so that first note comes in
so on the money okay okay i'll play
along when i hear that special song
this song just has to go well for her
because the fact that someone is going
to get cut is always in the back of my
mind you think that i can muster up a
little soft so gentle swaying but i
don't feel like dancing notes and no
dancing today don't feel like dancing
dancing she heard the music she
instantly was just like it took her away
and i could just see that and i was just
like man she wasn't thinking about fab
five she was just living the moment and
she could see me through the glass
and everybody in there boosting her up i
was like god this is amazing
[Music]
you